Welcome to the Heavey Spoilers show, I'm our
host Paul aka the biggest Wickhead on youtube
and this video we're gonna be talking about
a number of the big things that we've learned
about John Wick Chapter 4 since it's release.
In this video we're gonna be talking about
the alternate ending that they considered
using and also how the cast and crew reacted
to Lance Reddicks passing.
I wanna get straight into it but as we're
talking about the original ending we have
to give a spoiler alert up top before we get
into it. This scene was shot as an add on
to what we saw at the end and it may ruin
the film if you haven't checked it out yet.
With all that out the way, huge thank you
for clicking this, now let's get into John
Wick Chapter 4.
Ok so the movie ends with John taking down
the Marquis but in order to do that he has
to goade him into taking part in the duel
itself. In his arrogance once he sees that
John is seeminly beaten he decides to take
Caine's weapon and he goes to shoot Johh.
Wick didn't actually fire during the last
shot of the duel and he uses this opportunity
to kill the Marquis and free not only himself
but also Caine and his daughter.
However he's mortally wounded and he ends
up dying on the steps of the church after
uttering his wifes name Helen.
Now many people were shocked to see this scene
playing out as Wick was seen as this invincible
and unstoppable terminator that was the very
personification of the boogeyman.
-
Because of this many people have speculated
over the last couple of days that Wick is
actually still alive and there's been a lot
of wires getting crossed over whether he'll
return or not. There was a fifth John Wick
film greenlit along with four and thus there's
been talk that they just haven't announced
that so people go with the ending. Wick is
also due to appear in the Ana De Armas spin-off
the Ballerina and you can see how rumours
can spread.
-
No not like Baba Yaga. However, Chad Stahelski
has been doing a lot of press over the last
couple of days and he's discussed an alternate
ending they shot and cleared up a lot of things.
So originally Chapter 5 was in the works and
they were going to shoot it back to back with
Chapter 4. However he said that they realised
they'd rather do one movie they can put their
all into instead of making two concurrently.
The Ballerina is also set between the events
of chapter 3 and 4 so it doesnt really retcon
the ending either.
Now as for that ending, when the director
and Keanue went to the studio to pitch the
idea they kicked off and said that they were
insane for killing off their big cash cow.
In an interview with the Hollywood Reporter,
Chad said that the crew ended up having to
shoot an alternate ending for the film that
left John alive.
When discussing it he said that they initially
werte unsurue over whether to do a fourth
movie and they came up with the Why which
would ultimately be Johns Death. They realised
that they'd kinda fallen into a formula with
these movies where there were the same sorts
of beats and Chad even said that if he was
a fan then he would've watched Chapter 3 thinking
'how is he going to get out of this, just
give me an ending.'
So Chapter 4 was pitched as something that
the franchise hadn't tackled before which
was consequences and a conclusion.
He said that they very much felt like this
film should be a goodbye to John but they
wondered how to give a proper one. Thus they
came up with the idea that's laced throughout
the movie which is that a good death only
comes after a good life. He said that sums
up the movie and that the entire film is about
an action packed thrill ride in which John
gets his redemption in the end.
Now Chad then went into the test screenings
that they did and the times that they showed
the alternate ending to audiences.
According to the director the ending was almost
identical all the way up to the funeral scene.
We even had that play out exactly the same
however Johns Dog would longingly look over
and from here we'd get it confirmed that John
was still alive. This is why we had that shot
in the movie and also Winston and The Bowery
King discussing whether he was in heaven or
hell. Because they said neither that also
implied that he was still alive and out there
somewhere which is something we pointed out
in our breakdown of the movie.
However the fact that Chad is saying that
all these ideas were eventually cut down means
that the intention was indeed to kill him.
So put away your tin foil hats, John is intended
to be dead...but...with it being Hollywood
you never know how they're gonna work stuff
in. I'm talking The Ballerina introducing
cloning technology or something.
Now this ending didn't go down to well either
and apparently after the test screening they
realised that it wasn't a good fit for how
they'd made their movie. Everything about
it is centred around death and in bringing
back John it somewhat cheapened the message.
They talked about how this film was about
him realising that he'd ruined so many of
his friends lives and had killed hundreds
and hundreds of people in order to avenge
his dog. Thus they wanted to give some finality
and consequences to that so they had him saving
a friend before his death which acted somewhat
as redemption.
In the end the studio told them that they
could go with whatever ending they felt strongest
about. This is what we got in the final cut
with John passing away and his death being
final....for now.
Anyway this film is of course filled with
death, most notably Charons. Played by Lance
Reddick the actor sadly passed away whilst
the creative team were promoting the film
and this has been a tragic conversation topic
centred around the film. Lance died just as
the film was being sent out to the press for
screenings and Chad talked about what the
creative team felt upon learning this. He
said that both he and Keanu were massive fans
of the actor because of the Wire and that
he was one of the first people they cast after
getting Keanu for the role.
He said that when they initially pitched the
idea for the first film that it was difficult
getting people to show interest because they
said it was about a man who's dog was killed
and he got revenge. It didn't really work
in pitch meetings and thus many people turned
it down.
However they said to Lance:
“You’re going to be Charon the gatekeeper.John
Wickis going to be like Greek mythology.
It’s a fantasy film likeLord of the Rings,
but in modern day.” and he instantly got
it.
Now cut to Chapter 4 and he said that when
they pitched the idea to Lance about his reaction
to his death, Chad told the Hollwyood Reporter.
“Look, I can’t tell you I love it. I can’t
tell you I’m not upset, but I can tell you
that I don’t know another way to make this
movie this good.”
Chad later went on to talk about how his characters
death is the catalyst in the movie that really
kicks things off and it's a major driving
force for Winston. The Marquis didn't want
to make Winston one as it would give people
a reason to fight. However, in killing Charon
he very much made one for Winston who aided
John throughout the film.
Now when talking about it Chad said:
Cut to last Friday, we had literally just
got off the plane in Toronto, but it seemed
to be a very exciting and positive time. All
the screenings had been going really well,
and we’d been so fortunate to have good
responses. So we’d been talking to Lance
probably every other day, and we had just
seen him during the L.A. press, We left him
with a high five, going, “Catch you later!”
And then when we got off the plane, Derek
Kolstad, the original writer who’s very
close with Lance and his family, called me
and said that Lance had passed. We hadn’t
even put the bags in the room yet, and I made
one call to Keanu. He answered and I was like,
“Hey, man. I gotta come see you in your
room.” And he was like, “Sure, come on
up.”
So he opened the door, and I was like, “Look,
I have some bad news. Lance just passed away.”
And after the initial “what the f***?”
shock, everything went quiet. And then Keanu
looked at me and we were like, “This is
for him.” We only had two or three hours
before we had to go on stage in Toronto and
do the thing again, but that’s obviously
nothing compared to what his family and his
close friends are going through. So, for the
next hour and a half before our screening,
we just told Lance stories, and we realized
how lucky we were to have worked with him.
It was one of the most fortunate times in
my life.
Now the movie had been sent out to cineams
already and they said that it's extremely
difficult to recall the DCPs that get sent
out to cinemas. However even before Chad asked
Lionsgate to add something to the end the
Studio had been hard at work and they had
been making calls and getting it out there.
They said that not every single screening
will have the dedication added onto the end
but I saw it on mine and I know that others
did.
Chad did say that by the time it hits streaming
and so on that the dedication will be in place
and that they can make sure that Lance is
remembered for the great man that he is.
And that concludes the video, I hope you enjoyed
learning this extra information on the movie
even if a lot of it is to do with tragedy
both on and off screen.
Let me know your thoughts below and hopefully
I'll see you on the next video.
We’re running a competition right now and
giving away The Superman 4k Boxset to 3 Subscribers
on The 15th Of April. All you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like the
video, make sure you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode. We pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so message
me @heavySpoilers if that’s you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming. We break down
the entire thing so it’s definitely worth
checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time. Take care, Peace